j'ai refusé de jouer c'est la nouvelle
star tout simplement parce que j'étais
encore au lycée à l'époque j'avais à
peine 16 ans et que c'est peut-être pas
une priorité pour moi donc j'ai préféré
finir mon bac
est ce qu'il ya beaucoup arrangé
j'adorerais pouvoir travailler si on
partait dans nos rêves à l'envers et
sheeran bientôt voilà si elle va prendre
en plus de son talent le sondé en chute
dans dix ans j'espère continuer je sais
pas où je me vois en tout cas j'espère
continuer de faire des choses que j'aime
et qui nous font vibrer que ce soit la
musique ou la comédie donc je sais pas
on verra des portes qui s'ouvrent à moi
mais en tout cas j'espère avoir la
chance de pouvoir encore bien que de mes
passions pour aller où
j'ai tourné j'ai tourné le clip de pour
aller où
à essaouira au maroc on peut-on acheter
cette ville parce qu'on a tourné début
novembre et qu'on a la lumière et
le soleil et puis en bus je veux dire ce
qu'il en est il ya un nombre de paysage
complètement dingue
à ce moment là c'est une vie qui plein
de surprises et c'était vraiment trop
cool désert mer montagne strawberry
[Musique]